[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi ha paura della stampa 3d e se
facciamo un passo indietro nella vostra
memoria
chi ha paura della matematica e un passo
di lato della meccanica
buona sera io sono qui questa sera per
mettere insieme bellezza e imperfezione
macchine umani
chi guardando 4 equazione in quattro
incognite un sistema non prova un
sottile momento di disagio li conosco un
paio in sala secondo me che il gioco
stanno provando o anche solo guardando
una catena magari da riparare non prova
un fastidio la stampa 3d
quando è arrivata nella società erano
solo cinque anni fa sembrava diversa io
spero che non sia ancora diversa nel
rapporto tra noi e la tecnica ma quando
è arrivata
cinque anni fa era nota da 30 ha
generato curiosità e stupore molto
stupore e tanta fiducia perché abbiamo
cominciato a dire che facciamo
faremo e abbiamo fatto quella stampa 3d
cose straordinarie
proprio come abbiamo sentito sulla
stazione orbitante queste samantha lei
ha di fronte
sulla stazione orbitante internazionale
una stampante a tratti come quelle che
abbiamo in laboratorio e queste bacche
il suo comandante che stampa che ha in
mano un oggetto identico a questo questo
è un cricchetto una chiave e perché
posso dire con qualche orgoglio e
simpatia uno per funziona
2 che è stato stampato nel nostro
laboratorio al politecnico di milano e 3
che è stato stampato con un file
disegnato alla nasa spedito sulla
stazione orbitante
e poi rilasciato gratuitamente sul sito
www.nasa.gov e chiunque di voi ma la
scarica se è una stampante a casa di già
un figlio elio un fidanzato nerd cielo
stampa e se no va nei centri di stampa
che sempre di più proviamo nelle nostre
città eccolo lì il cricchetto magico la
stampa 3d è una tecnologia che ha
compiuto
diciamo che apre un brevetto 30 anni
circa
questo è anche il motivo per cui la
vediamo tanto di più adesso questo si
chiama it cycle e il ciclo dello stupore
della visibilità è una cosa è colpa
economisti quindi io non lo sono
lo tratta con rispetto però guardate
quella curva tutte le tecnologie nel
tempo passano da un innesco dove tutti
dicono adesso arriva arriva la nuova
tecnologia e farà grandi cose e allora
arriva il picco delle aspettative
gonfiate di faremo adesso tutti subito
un cuore stampato in 3d ma attenzione
che la tecnologia una cosa seria e
inevitabilmente si deve confrontare con
la realtà è inevitabilmente il ciclo il
ciclo di hype ve lo stupore della
visibilità passa per la forza della
disillusione solo le tecnologie più vere
salgono sulla salita dell'illuminazione
e arrivano all'altopiano della
produttività
mi dicono un secondo che se pensate a
rapporti fra umani allo strizzi co
aspettativa gonfiata la difficoltà è più
bravi
salgono e vanno all'altopiano della
felicità
la similitudine mi sarà più familiare
in questi cinque anni tutti hanno
cominciato a parlare stampa tardi per
una semplice ragione perché cinque anni
fa sono scaduti i primi brevetti e una
grande comunità che si chiama comunità
dei metri ha fatto sì che quei brevetti
non andassero persi come molti ogni
giorno ma venissero raccolti e questi
numeri sono veri il mercato mondiale
della stampa 3d o della manifattura di
tv miliardi di dollari si è quasi triplo
più che raddoppiato in tre anni
e questi che vedete sono numeri veri di
proiezioni i miliardi di dollari nei
prossimi sette anni a cominciare dei
dieci successivi al 2015
però quando una cosa va così forte e non
rispetta sempre le aspettative la
diffidenza può innescare brutti scherzi
quella valle della quella che qualcuno
chiama la valle della morte genera può
generare uno stigma e dunque adesso sono
tutti a chiederci a cosa servirà mai
questa stampa 3d
e allora noi al più lab il laboratorio
di stampa tradire il dipartimento di
chimica e materiali del politecnico di
milano abbiamo deciso di ricominciare a
ragionare
attraverso la stampa 3d sul fare e lo
abbiamo fatto attraverso un approccio
che viene definito frugale che vuol dire
in parole povere fare di più o meno
usiamo stampanti e quando costano poco
costano 200 dollari
e quando quest'anno tanto ne contano
2000 eccolo qui i banconi sono quelli di
nata veramente gli stessi li faceva la
chimica analitica e vinceva il premio
nobel e noi abbiamo deciso di ritornare
a sporcarci le mani ea fare oggetti di
uso quotidiano sfruttando una delle cose
che la stampa 3d fa meglio non avendo
stampi personalizza e pirandello dice la
fantasia abbellisce gli oggetti e
nell'oggetto noi amiamo quel che vi
mettiamo di noi questo muta radicalmente
il rapporto tra noi e gli oggetti
abbiamo altresì deciso di fare con tutti
perché fare è di tutti è uno dei nostri
hashtag preferiti
abbiamo lanciato un progetto piccolo che
sono qui oggi a consegnare nelle vostre
mani
il progetto si chiama più ability quello
il logo con la sua faccia arancione
queste sono le facce di un po delle
persone arancioni che sono passati in
questi anni tre tra di noi è quello il
primo oggetto se io chiedo in giro che
cos'è è un gancio come lo usereste per
il tavolo attacchiamo e mettiamo la
borsa invece di metterla a terra per
esempio siamo troppo facile alziamo un
po il tiro
questo cos'è si usa con dentro un
qualcosa che non mi dico ora è sì così e
così ve lo dico tra un secondo
questo invece è un braccetto rom è un
braccetto robotico stampato per più del
50 per cento in 3d loro due sono a
sinistra laura a destra giulia e
rispettivamente sono una ragazza
meravigliosa che tira di scherma e
l'altra che studia fa cose fantastiche
con i robot luna e cieca e l'altra è
affetta da altro glee posi il gancetto
l'ha fatto laura per attaccare il suo
bastone bianco al tavolo perché quando
mette il bastone bianco per terra dopo
non lo trovi e si sporca
questo è uno spalma nutella perché laura
come i bambini
esce dalla fetta di pane lamette qui
e con questa rack la us palmi in una
direzione nell'altra il braccetto
robotico è un tentativo un inizio di
altare giulia a mangiare da sola questa
e laura che ha fatto l'alternanza scuola
dal lavoro da noi laboratorio con
valerio gabriele e da sola con i ragazzi
ha imparato anche a stampare in 3d la
folha
perché come dicevamo anche nella prima
parte e il possibile che va esplorato
questionato progetto noi non ci fermiamo
questi sono oggetti di uso quotidiano
ancora che cos'è questo si monta così
come l'avete visto linee dalla foto
eccolo qua
che cos'è leva torsolo della mela
potrebbe essere un ottimo spunto un
apribottiglie esattamente e questo look
che cos'è che cos'è questo tagliamo
sempre un po di livello smonta si monta
e si usa lo dico dopo e pensami su che
cos'è che cosa è questo ma pinzetta per
francobolli hanno detto l'altro giorno
e invece guardate un po basil il nome di
questo l'ha fatto stefania che come
tutte le ragazze che seguono a parte di
una grande associazione di pazienti
reumatici
le ragazze hanno l'artrite reumatoide
perlopiù o patologie che deformano le
loro mani quindi daisy affatto look per
aprire le bottiglie affatto daisy per
aprire le bottiglie italia ha fatto look
per aiutarsi con la cintura di sicurezza
quando torce il busto e fa fatica e
maria grazia ha fatto pensami su per
estrarre il bancomat ha dalla sua sede
perché non riuscendo a porre bene il
pollice il bancomat a ruba
queste sono esperienze straordinarie che
noi abbiamo potuto vivere in questi anni
sono solo alcune scelte e se voi andate
anche adesso sul sito www.abi.it
prendete il telefono immaginiamo di
lanciare il video che c'è qua sotto e di
vedere cosa succede eccolo andate lì e
potete partecipare lo farete spero dopo
dopo aver messo tutti i like nei nostri
social più abili di tutte queste cose
qua andate lì ci sono le storie
la storia che scegliamo e noi non ci
fermiamo ci sono tutti i protagonisti
questi nove meravigliosi co progettisti
che con noi hanno fatto cose
eccola stefania ha fatto daisy e con noi
l'ha progettato in un modo interattivo
andate lì e vedete questo lo potete
maneggiare smontare modificare nella
forma e nelle dimensioni cinque petali
sono pochi ne facciamo sei o sette e ci
adattiamo al antropometria delle nostre
mani tutte diverse
ecco che questo ci sembra un modo di
calare la stampa 3d nel concreto tra di
noi farle fare il ruolo di congiunzione
tra bisogni persone e altre persone
e così troviamo nuovi amici ne ho
trovato tantissimi amici perché è
proprio vero che ogni amico costituisce
un mondo dentro di noi solo quando
incontriamo un nuovo amico quel nuovo
mondo nasce e così l'estate scorsa
abbiamo incontrato carolina o meglio
carolina ha incontrato noi grillina
allieva di ingegneria dei materiali è
venuta mi ha detto prof
la vuole conoscere i miei amici di
believe ha detto beh perchè no vogliono
parlare stampa 3d e un po ne so andiamo
e così ci siamo trovati abbiamo
cominciato a fare qualche workshop
alessia e carolina si sono messi a fare
la tesi di alessi alessia si è laureata
due settimane fa in this and engineering
e alessia con carolina o meglio carolina
con alessia con tutti noi ha progettato
i e than it è un bracciale rigido ed
enna è un bracciale di silicone tutto
parte dal fatto che carolina sta facendo
la chemio e un giorno quando la li che
la facevo le ha detto beh certo non puoi
pretendere di essere comodo mentre ti
salva la vita
era uno sciocco che passava però intanto
carolina deve convivere con il picco un
catetere venoso che va portato a volte
per mesi a volte per anni per facilitare
la somministrazione dei farmaci
convivere col piccone a fatica e per
questo allo stato dell'arte ci sono
soluzioni come mette una bella garda
sopra o al 3 quando devi fare la doccia
di mettere della plastica allora alessia
con carolina hanno fatto un modello
personalizzabile in rete e l'hanno
trasformato in due oggetti che possono
essere indossati possono essere
indossati anche in acqua perchè quello
di silicone eppure impermeabile hanno
fatto un lavoro sulle forme che speriamo
di soddisfazione e pregio per aiutarci
ancora una volta a tutti a superare il
concetto di stigma lo stigma della
stampa 3d lo stigma della malattia
ci sono cose che hanno portano con sé un
significato duro e allora noi abbiamo
detto perché non cercare la bellezza e
così abbiamo fatto un altro progetto che
si chiama cicatrice cicatrici il
progetto più recente che facciamo quei
ragazzi di believer che sono un
associazione che unisce ragazzi
adolescenti che hanno patologie croniche
o malattie rare e li avvicina al mondo
del lavoro quindi noi per loro siamo
anche lavoro e e abbiamo deciso di
l'idea di giada abbiamo deciso di
prendere delle bellezze classiche qui ne
vedete una vi faccio osservare che lei
la venere è un prototipo nel senso che
non è stata neanche sinitra un bozzetto
una gamba neanche ce l'ha
fin dalla sua nascita e tempo le ha
tolto le braccia è quanto di più
imperfetto esista ma chi potrebbe dire
che lei il suo amico david un po tanto
palestrato è una bellezza assoluta anche
se non così più moderna non sono icone
della bellezza e lo abbiamo detto allora
prendiamo le cose a bellezza e
disegniamo su di loro le nostre
cicatrici quali tutti i ragazzi di vili
dilagasse il più lab
ci siamo esercitati e queste che vedete
qui sono delle veneri e dei david che
portano le nostre cicatrici perché il
nostro credere e che tutti abbiamo una
cicatrice e lasciare che la tecnologia
di a tridimensionalità tutto ciò ci è
sembrata una cosa che dà senso a un po
di nostre giornate
e così siccome qualcuno prima ha detto
che bisogna volare alto io ho pensato di
volare alto con due ragazzi che in
questo momento sono a lui una città dove
si fanno i giochi mattoncini e si
occupano di comunicazione e tutti i
nostri ragazzi abbiamo ideato tutti
insieme il nostro manifesto perché noi
più abili ti facciamo così noi
abbracciamo la diversità e ne facciamo
energia per il nostro progettare noi ha
più ability pensiamo di essere il ponte
che accorcia la distanza tra le persone
e le tecnologie noi ha più ability
creiamo luoghi dove si accoglie
l'innovazione e la bellezza è ciò che ci
emoziona noi ha più ability sogniamo
così da abbattere barriere e usare
tecnologie per cambiare il nostro modo
di vivere la società noi che abiliti
lavoriamo così
accogliamo l'umanità ne riconosciamo il
valore e la bellezza delle cicatrici per
dare un senso unità e forza al nostro
lavorare insieme
noi ha più abili ti facciamo così
facciamo il nostro manifesto alvaro e
lorenzo a lui vanno i grafici insieme
non hanno la mia età e ci hanno aiutato
a farlo questo manifesto da domani
questo manifesto sarà in rete
io non so nemmeno se sarò capace saremo
capaci di trovare un luogo dove
finalmente dare a tutti voi fatelo
girare più che potete e quindi a quelli
fuori la possibilità di aderire al
nostro meraviglioso più manifesto che
non so se sarà su facebook o altrove
cercate hashtag più manifesto e vedrete
che lo troverete
questi sono gli eroi
questi sono i rivoluzionari del fare che
non potendo essere qui ci salutano da
questa foto come se fossero tutti lì con
me a darmi coraggio e ci consentono in
anticipo sul tempo quindi posso anche
prendere fiato e rallentare mi
consentono di lasciarvi con il pensiero
più alto che io ho sentito dire ai
ragazzi di believe e che vi lascio qui
adesso la vita è troppo bella per avere
paura credetemi
[Applauso]